let's go to Rahman from Minneapolis
welcome back to the program what's going
on
thank you David how's your day going
today it's going well
yeah my first question is how would you
compare Donald Trump to past Republican
leaders like Richard Nixon Reagan Bush
and how and how they conducted business
in this country and their scandals well
I think that Trump has done
I mean listen compared to most of the
people you listed all of them Trump has
had way more wrongdoing that he's
engaged in than any of them I think the
difference is Trump has had the benefits
of the right wing media machine
including Fox News and Newsmax and
right-wing media and and Defenders to
the death on social media and on and on
and on but I think that look at the list
of all the things that Donald Trump has
done look just look at all the criminal
investigations that he's under right now
so I think that Trump is worse in terms
of misdeeds I think Trump's dumber than
most of them I mean Nixon was a horrible
person but he was quite smart
Reagan you know it was no genius but he
was he was relatively smart Bush was
kind of like when when it started with
the whole kind of dim thing but again
Bush seems like a Mensa member compared
to Trump so I I think that Trump is also
particularly just dumb in a very uh
superficial way
yeah like um what I believe is it like
if with Nixon he didn't have the right
wing media back then if he did I don't
think he would have been impeached
bright
I feel like with Donald Trump he's
essentially taken every he's just taking
every bad part of each of each of those
presidents like with Reagan he had the
Iran Contra scandal with Nixon was
watergating with bush it was uh it was
about lying about wmd's and and
torturing people yeah no absolutely and
I think your your spot on that had Nixon
had the benefit of this right-wing media
machine that was defending everything he
said all the time constantly it is quite
possible that public opinion among
Republicans would not have shifted
Republicans would not have gone to Nixon
and said listen if you don't resign
we're gonna have to impeach you and that
that it could have actually saved Nixon
and so that the really scary thing there
is more about
Trump did enough horrible things that
were it not for were it not for the
right-wing media apparatus Trump might
have had to resign Trump in the 70s
might have had to resign and that really
puts a big Spotlight for the horrible
destructive nature of right-wing media
and we should not forget that
yeah uh second question second question
before I go this is very quick
um with with a lot of people with a lot
of people going against progressives I'm
like progressives all they want to do is
make people's lives better like versus
Centrist versus right versus people in
the right wing uh progresses all the
other one do is make people's lives
better so why are so many people going
against them even though the the only
thing that they care about is making
everybody on the uh have a same equal
footing in this country yeah no I uh I
completely agree with your perspective
and the Counterpoint is the right would
say no no no listen
as the government what we want the
government doing is not making people
lives better it's letting people live
the life they want to live and if some
people don't want a better life then we
should allow them to do it it's a nanny
state that forces themselves upon you
that's the way that the right would
approach it
yeah but when Republicans talk about
small government small government and
say not people's lives yeah they're
actually lying to people with
progressives of course they they
actually they actually want to stay out
of people's lives and make people's
lives better that's all they really want
to do I agree with you I agree with you
completely but good luck convincing a
republican of that all right all right
Rock one from Minneapolis great to hear
from you again very much appreciated
let's go to Alex from Baltimore Alex
welcome back to the program
hello
hey David can you hear me yes I can
all right uh real quick I wanted to say
congrats on the baby it's been a little
while how much has your espresso budget
uh increased since then you know it
really hasn't changed dramatically I
have to tell you because you know one of
the things this I hate to admit this but
uh with my particular espresso machine I
am much better at getting a double shot
just right than a single so often what I
do and I know it's wasteful but at the
end of the day it's just water even if I
only want a single shot I'm usually
making a double and then just dumping
the second shot that I don't want so all
that I've really been doing sometimes is
just having the second shot so it hasn't
really changed the budget
well lucky you yeah now white is that
surprising
um well just with with our child it was
a lot rough goings the first few months
with sleep so I definitely had lots of
red eyes and extra coffee and all that
stuff listen it's rough but it's like
how much coffee am I Really Gonna Have
you know
that's fair I was just playing around
all right I mean I guess a lot is the
answer who knows yeah fair enough uh
real question yeah so I had I had
something about um
uh eliminating the filibuster so I'm not
against it in principle or anything okay
but I but I do Wonder like and we just
got rid of it period like for example
Trump's first two years in office
wouldn't they have just been able to
just pass all sorts of crazy horrible
stuff and
how would we stop that without the
filibuster and or is that just a risk we
have to take to get stuff done now yeah
unfortunately listen the retrospective
stuff I think is fine it's like well
listen if we only needed 51 instead of
60 on this then it might have passed or
whatever the problem is that usually
when people talk about that you're going
backwards only a very narrow amount of
time and also so what you have to think
about is imagine that the filibuster had
been previously done away with and then
think about all the things Republicans
would have been able to pass when they
had the opportunity and also if
Democrats did away with the filibuster
now think about what that would mean for
republicans and what they're willing to
do at some future point so I think
that's all fine I I really do think the
right way to think about the filibuster
is less about what could we have done
during this narrow window but what might
they do it should just be listen
at its core
are there certain things where there
should be 60 votes in favor or should
everything just be 51. I actually think
we need to just be honest about how it
needs to be organized are there things
where we should have even more support
than that because they are so
significant and impactful to American
life I don't pretend to know the answer
but I think the best way to think about
this is less about we could have done
this if we had gotten rid of the
filibuster in January of 2020. I don't I
don't know I mean yes we can play that
game but it really is about does it make
sense that in this country you need a
simple majority or are there certain
things where you actually should have a
60 majority or even greater and to start
with that rather than just the politics
of it if that makes sense
yeah no I get that I would just
personally I would say split the
difference and make it 55 that's just my
personal
take take it or leave it yeah I mean
listen it's it's a matter there's no
right answer it's like so you could have
someone who says you know I think
anything that has to do with taxes
should have 57 votes and anything with
health health care should have 55 and
anything with budget should be you
everybody will have a different opinion
and I don't know that there's any right
or wrong necessarily but fundamentally
that's the philosophical question that
this is all about
right I just want to hear your take I
appreciate it all right Alex from
Baltimore thank you very much let's go
next to Jojo from California JoJo
welcome to the show what's on your mind
JoJo from California what's on your mind
JoJo from California your turn to speak
you're unmuted uh you're on you can
speak now
all right JoJo from California clearly
having
uh apparently some kind of technical
issues of various kinds Jojo I uh I'm
sorry that we are not going to be able
to speak but there is some kind of
technical problem half JoJo you're muted
yourself JoJo are you back now
no
all right well JoJo's gone let's go to
Chris Chris welcome to the program
what's on your mind
Chris you're on the program what's going
on
so what you're live right now
there's that one that
Chris your life uh this is David Chapman
welcome
hi there we go
Chris you're on the air right now and we
can hear you go on my friend
oh I'm sorry I'm sitting here listening
I'm at work right now my guy yeah I'm
talking to you Chris
yeah I'm saying I'm at work right now I
can't talk I was just listening in go
all right okay Brook's going okay for
you
yeah yeah I apologize no no no I
apologize what kind of work do you do
um mandatory the beer distributor really
yeah what's going on with the Beer World
these days
in fact it was a lot of ipas coming out
is it is it just an IPA Fiasco these
days
yeah like right now I got a case in here
that's worth uh 120 the 24 beers oh my
goodness what country is that from
yeah we'll bear them and uh right
outside of Philadelphia
sorry what was that Billy
I said How's my boy Jimmy from Philly
doing I have no idea
yeah you haven't been playing any of his
uh voicemails people we haven't been
getting any
wow
concerning well Chris listen a pleasure
having you on all right my friend
thank you my guy all right there is
Chris from Pennsylvania and I think we
gotta call it quits when we're ahead
folks so we are gonna do it for calls
for the week we will speak to more
people next week we'll take a quick
break and then get to your emails and
many more things quick break and back
after this